All right; let's wrap this up.
Over the entire course, we've seen lexing, parsing; we just saw optimizing.
We've seen interpreting.
And just in case anything goes wrong, we know how to do debugging.
Lexing was based on regular expressions.
They specify sets of strings, and they can be implemented under the hood
with finite state machines.
Parsing uses context-free grammars, which can capture behavior
like balanced parentheses that regular expressions can't.
And we saw how to implement those with dynamic programming,
that is, writing ourselves little memos in a chart, and parse states.
Optimizations are great; they make the programs simpler
and conserve some important resource like time or power or heat dissipation.
But they're only valid if they retain the meaning.
In general, interpreting refers to walking the abstract syntax tree recursively
and computing the final value.
In our particular web browser, our HTML interpreter calls the JavaScript interpreter,
and our HTML interpreter calls the graphics interpreter.
And in debugging and testing we can gain confidence that our program adheres
to its specification by thinking very hard about which parts of the input
or which parts of the program might be wrong
and carefully crafting them, paying attention to all the information we have available.
In the homework or the class final projects, you'll finish the browser,
and unit 7 will be review for the final exam.